hey what's up party people welcome to
another
episode of what is it today i'm going to
share this commentary for pride the last
dragon that's what it is doing great
yeah you know how this goes i'm with
danielle i'm with lon
we uh we watch the australia together we
tell you all of our deepest darker
secrets that we harbor about this film
uh we'll show you some deleted scenes we
will take your questions we will tease
you with next week's honest trailer
you guys know how it works by now um but
we're talking about ryan the last dragon
which is tricky because
since i've last thought about ryan the
last dragon and today
i saw the snyder cut which just kind of
reduced my brain
to a a dc patina slurry
and that's all i can really think about
um but
taking myself back to a pre-snyder cut
universe thinking about ryan the last
dragon
i think i enjoyed this film from what i
recall it was definitely
a sumptuous visual delight um
but otherwise kind of a uh kind of a
cookie-cutter disney adventure story not
like a disney princess story but like
your kind of
standard action adventure uh mystical
land
thing that was very avatar heavy that's
what i think i thought of it
but let's say you refresh my memory
about ryan the last dragon you guys
i didn't like where ryan revealed that
she was actually the martian man hunter
and oh wait no hang on no i'm getting it
i got i got mixed
did you know every character at least
one character in every movie is martian
the manhunt
got to look at the eyes if they start
going red that's how you know
oh harry lennox is busy yeah uh what are
you guys overall thoughts on this film
if you can remember any of them after
our dew soaked snyder cut watch
who uh i really loved it i really liked
the movie um
i thought that it was super cute i uh
there were moments where
sisu i i thought that they were going
too hard to try to be funny and it's
like no like
she's an awkward dragon you don't really
get to see that um i
ship raya and namari hard i hard ship it
um but yeah i just thought it was really
cute and it did it looked really really
gorgeous it's a great story
very lore heavy uh definitely like i
would watch
the you know uh disney morning or
whatever
cartoon of that because there's a lot
there that they could expand on
um so yeah i really really liked it i
assume it'll get a sequel and i look
forward to that
you assume it'll get a sequel that's
interesting i wonder because i wonder if
anybody bothered to
watch this film um yeah because we'll
never know right
it's disney plus they don't release
their numbers they're assuring us it did
great
so okay they're like we promise
everybody's watching everything it's
good i mean it did come out really
yeah numbers but it came out
theatrically sort of right and it and
it's
uh lost to tom and jerry which you never
want to lose to tom and jerry
no you're there i i i don't know like i
wanted to get more on board
i feel really divided on this one it's
beautiful it's stunningly beautiful it's
one of the most
visually like impressive amazing
animated movies like maybe ever i feel
like disney's getting to the
pixar-esque level where it's like
incredible visuals and
like uh we we have a little riff about
the water in here but just like
there's so many just like vistas and
scenes and
the character design is really
interesting and everything visual like i
i feel like i would have enjoyed the
movie just as much with no sound
uh i it because everything else kind of
felt a little paint by numbers to me it
just felt like
like there was everything was kind of
like one level and all the characters
have like their bit
and like we didn't get to spend enough
time with anyone to sort of get past
their bit
and sort of get a little more
development there and so i just thought
it was a lot of like interesting ideas
that never really get to go anywhere but
in this incredible world that i enjoyed
spending time with just because it looks
great
yeah well yeah i hope it gets sequels
and spin-offs um i think we say in the
trailer that this deserved its own
series its own time to breathe you know
yeah in some ways i think that's
probably one of the big
setbacks is that it's so big it is more
like a pilot in a lot of ways where it's
setting up this whole world and all of
these
lands and tribes and mythology and then
it's just like well we gotta just get to
the end is like the gems fight over the
gems okay done
and it's like it does kind of feel like
we don't really get past the surface on
anything because there's just so much
being presented to us
so yeah like it would lend itself to a
series if disney feels like
taking another swing at it yeah well
there you go
it's now all coming back to me and i
think i agree with what you guys are
saying
but let's confirm by watching a lot like
avatar yeah i remember that
let's watch the honest trailer for what
is this thing again
avatar the last dragon bender
[Music]
fang heart spine
talon and tail long ago
the five lands lived together in harmony
then
everything changed when the drew nation
attacked only the dragons could stop
them
but when the world needed the most they
vanished
500 years past and raya discovered the
last dragon
a water dragon named sisu and although
her magic skills are great
she has a lot to learn before she's
ready to save anyone
but raya believes sisu can save the
world
riotar the last air dragon
i mean we're not lon you actually
outlined it in your notes of the
many many parallels um
yeah it it it really goes into way more
uh depth than we do in the trailer
but you've got a world divided by
feuding city state nations each with
their own little visual theme and custom
fighting style
and they're all kind of cherry-picked
from different uh asian traditions
mostly southeast asian
and then you have like this immature
hero who's been asleep for centuries and
then a girl from a water tribe who
separated from her father
i mean even there were like specific
things like there's like hybrid kinds of
animals that mix
two earth animals together or like and
you know she's riding around on
hers as a as a ball creature whereas
aang has a flying bison banang also
rides around on a ball of air a lot like
a lot of the visual ideas seem kind of
lifted
it yeah and then like obviously the fire
nation
uh you know fang fang and then the zero
character
go have a similar arc like if there's a
lot of similarities
look it works i mean i'm it
avatar becomes the template for uh for
kids movies rather than
god i don't know cinderella or whatever
it has been for the last two decades but
sure i don't know they did not really
hide their influence well i i know they
say it's it's influenced by southeast
asian culture in an aesthetic way but
like
plot-wise and story-wise it's avatar the
last airbender like 100
yeah i feel like you do like you could
take your inspiration there but
spread it around like give a give at
least pick one
other property to like kind of lift from
instead of just making it like what if
disney but
avatar but disney but we owned it though
well the great art of steel right um
let's uh
let's keep going i mean raya and the
last dragon
journey to commandra a melting pot of
southeast asian cultures
and east asian voice actors to meet raya
an orphan warrior princess and total
dragon nerd
i might be a little bit of a dragon nerd
you're not
the only dragon nerd here which in a
world created by dragons
means she's super religious raya will
find a savior who can walk on water when
she awakens sisu
an orphaned cross between a thai naga
and a stretched out my little pony
who can disguise herself as a cross
between aquafina and an e-girl on
laundry day
together i thought they they made that
dragon very
very huggable i thought that looked like
such a nice soft dragon
i really like the design of uh of
aquafina or of sisu but i think that
it'd be tough to get like do they make
like life-size versions of that as far
as plushes go i feel like that thing
would take up an entire kid's bedroom
it would have to be the bed like those
old race car beds
yeah they just have to be a bed that's a
dragon with a dragon head in the front
uh it it it is gonna be interesting to
see
uh if sisu walks around the parks
because it would
be like kind of tall you're gonna need
like a tall thin person
yeah that's the problem i feel like it
was kind of a cop out to to turn sisu
into a human um but i feel like that's
what you're gonna get at the park you'll
get the you'll get the aquafina you'll
get the
feedback it's a young dragon version
yeah
i want the i want the 50 foot long
uh uh plush and i wanted to snake around
um and be able to uh to wrap my arms
around it because i think they did they
they made it so
the fur man the just the the texture on
that thing looked incredible
yeah i mean that that's kind of what i'm
saying like i remember when monster's
ink came out they made a big deal about
like
sully's fur like there's a program that
randomizes all the strands of fur so
they move like
natural hair wood in all sorts of
different directions and like
now when you watch this that looks
terrible like
in comparison like like even the
incredible state of the art of early
pixar when you look at something like
this now
it's on a totally different level like
the the granular specifics of texture
you're able to bring out
uh and so yeah i totally agree like it's
like incredible when you first see it
it's like
a you know a flying furry dre looks like
a like a my little pony come to life
yeah so twilight sparkle of our dreams
yeah props for that and i i do like
sisu's character and but i totally agree
with you danielle i do think we bring it
up later is like
they didn't need to do so many 2010 isms
of like i don't know it's just i know
it's like magical
and and i don't again i know they've
done it before with like the genie and
aladdin and stuff like that but
it just when the when the dragon sounds
like someone doing like a a twitter clap
back it's like just just leave that out
of my fantasies
twitter is not a part of our fantasies
is what we're telling you yeah exactly
yeah i think it's like in something like
tom and jerry like
they're gonna floss like i i guarantee
you just
know that's part of it we accept that
it's the genre whatever but it's
something like this i'm trying to
immerse
myself into like a different mode you
know it's like a transport of epic
fantasy like
that breaks the reality and there's
something they don't lost thank goodness
does not floss i don't want to i don't
want to put that yeah but but that's the
thing is the
for these feature-length animated films
you need to bake in
the jokes like a couple years in advance
and like the the the pace of comedy has
gotten
where like things are funny for like an
afternoon so
the the the hubris of putting in like a
flossing joke
or i don't know what's funny right now
uh uh
having shrimp tails in your cinnamon
toast crunch or something like that
and assuming that two years from now
people will still
understand that or appreciate that and
it won't be um cringe as the kids say is
is insane um so just just keep your
humor timeless okay don't uh
don't talk about pop and locking or
whatever although pop blocking is
timeless as well
anyways keep going yeah they did they
did good on that one it's still a thing
laundry day together cecil will teach
raya the importance of learning to trust
others while the movie will teach you to
never trust anyone
in a different world maybe we could have
been friends you're going to tell me
where i can find those other
dragon gem pieces who's baby
what
you have to give a little trust first
say so don't
it was foolish to trust someone from fat
don't come any closer
you're saying give people a chance but
you're showing that chaos is a letter
travel across this richly detailed land
so quickly
you wish they had an avatar length tv
series to explore it further
as you spend barely enough time with the
orphan boone a tragic victim of
millennial hustle culture
i'm captain boone the owner chef and
chief financial officer of the shrimp
oil
noy a tiny orphan martial artist who
feels like an exchange student from the
boss baby franchise
all right boss this actually lined up so
well like i couldn't believe how much it
does look like a an option
a boss baby character yeah this baby
is from an entirely different
film um and i guess that's fine but it's
so clear that like
they just love the baby and they thought
that the baby jokes where like a baby
acts like an adult was so funny
and it i don't know if it is the baby
was probably the only part where i was
like i don't understand this baby like
how could this baby fight
well what's legitimate diapers you think
for a while like i thought for at least
a seat or two there's another level to
this but like we're gonna get a reveal
it's like
not a real it's an enchanted it's an
adult in the body of a baby or that
somebody's controlling the baby or it's
another dragon or something
but like eventually you're like no it's
just like a baby who's just like
babies in this universe are incredibly
smart and precocious
and like basically are just adults in
baby bodies
and you get like half a beat of
acknowledgement of like
it's actually pretty tragic that this
baby's parents are dead and it was left
to be raised by monkeys on the street
that's the thing that thread is like i
feel like there's another
there's like release here's what the
thing is release the snyder cut
of ryan last dragon folks i do feel like
there's an earlier cut
where we spend more time on that concept
that this is a
world of orphans like the drone is
killing everybody
and so everybody's lost people like
nobody has their family
intact and like that's really touching
and sad it does feel like a disney epic
kind of setup
and but we only we only get little drips
and drabs of it we never really explore
it as an idea that
she's gathering this community of
orphans around her because everybody is
an orphan in this world
um so yeah it's that was so quickly
because they want to get to the next
like comedy beat and i i feel like we
we don't spend enough time on that as a
concept
more time with how sad that baby is yeah
i mean i don't think you have to like
really luxuriate in the tragedy of
everybody having dead parents
but they they make such a big just a big
to-do of it with raya oh my parents are
dead
but then when you when you have the same
thing with the baby
but then it's only played for like i'm a
kick-ass baby i'm gonna kick you in the
face
that's what i mean it's just like as a
thread not not that we need to like
dwell on it for several scenes in a row
but just as a thread that we're pulling
through everywhere we go
yeah you know it rather than it just
being like i'm booty here's my quirky
thing and like i'm a baby and here's my
thing and then like i'm benedict wong
that's kind of my bit
like you know like i didn't i wanted
more than just their bit
like i'm better than guang remember me
from doctor strange still me
got only one eye now but basically the
same let's go grab some gems together
yeah
right let's go make some jokes about how
i like food
all right keep going
anton a likely orphan who's lost his
only child
hey wait a second raya sisu boon noi
tong
did disney just pull off the rare
quintuple orphan gang
bravo that is some really efficient
parent killing right there
heroes beware dark clouds are gathering
on the horizon
not metaphorically the bad guy is
literally dark clouds
because when you unleash the imagination
of disney animators
these days they'll come back with what
if cloud but bad
and with a villain this lane you better
hope the real enemy was inside us all
along or whatever
as the main antagonist turns out to be
raya's on again off again maybe
friendship may be something more
with namari she may have doomed them all
when they were kids
it's fangs now she may have doomed them
all again when they grew up
she may be dooming everyone outside of
her own tribe we need to expand if we
had all the gem pieces
we could do that safely but when you
really think about it aren't the heroes
just as much to blame for triggering the
end of the world
you're as much to blame for sisu's death
as i am
actually no no she is not i'm sorry but
no
we've been watching them that that
really annoyed me
i i get where they're coming from but
actually i don't even get where they're
coming from
like they really make the antagonists
like they they explain where they're
coming from but there is no doubt that
fang is effing things up for everybody
else and then they
the way they play that beat is
everyone's like you're right you're
right we uh like what could they have
done differently they kept
assassinating people i think that this
this kind of goes back we've got a
couple different sections that come at
this from different ways but i think the
idea is the movie keeps saying like
here's what the message of the movie is
but the characters don't actually
learn that lesson over the course of the
movie they're just
told the lesson like they don't their
journey doesn't teach them you need to
trust people
in fact their trust is never once
rewarded like
like the times they do trust people
they're screwed over for it like
raya opens the movie being trusting
that's not her dilemma that she needs to
learn how to trust
that's the mistake she makes is she
trusts the wrong person and loses the
gem
so i feel like it's just a structural
problem they had early on that they
didn't ever quite figure out
was like we've got the lesson the
character needs to learn and then we've
got the trip that she's actually on
and they don't necessarily culminate in
the same place
what you're saying is the same thing
it's like well we have to teach her the
lesson in the end
and the only way to make the lesson
clear is like we're all at fault because
we didn't work together
but that's not actually what the
scenario was yeah and what i thought
they were setting up was going to be
like the
the like a violation of trust between
her
and her father because like he was he
kept telling
her that like all the other nations like
you know they're just they're just kind
of bitter i'm not sure why they hate us
so much but we can get them all together
and then
when she leaves her you know walled
garden she finds out that everybody
outside of it is starving to death
yep and like he's like i just they're
just superstitious they just want like
they hate us for our freedom basically
yeah so i thought that they were going
to explain that like her tribe actually
was
kind of this hegemonic oppressor of the
rest of them and like she had to that's
why she had to take the first step and
like kind of apologize and
make good but no they just uh they were
just jealous they were just jealous
haters
because that's like that they've got it
they've got to toe the side i'm not
saying it's easy this is really hard to
do but they've got to tell this item
it's got to be a rousing adventure like
it can't be a lesson in like
oh we were the bad guys all along
because that's not a rousing adventure
that's depressing
so you've got to balance a lot of these
different needs when you're making this
kind of a story
uh and i just feel like it's like they
got they got like 90
of the way to closing the circle like
they did it's almost there
i'm going to give them partial credit
yeah stop looking for uh to disney
movies to answer
you know centuries old political
philosophy questions um
or really anything except entertainment
yeah maybe if you have rice
and other people don't give them some
rice share some of that rice
yeah what he's trying to do in the
beginning he's like he invites them for
a big
feast and then but fang will just waste
it on their elaborate
cats dicks about it yeah like you know
they wouldn't know what to do with it
with their undercuts and their large
battle felines
um anyways let's keep going we've been
watching the movie
you shot her no so try to stomach a
story that feels like it was let's say
reincarnated from another franchise with
enough 2010's banter to repeatedly take
you out of it
do you mean captain popping lock over
there here i was worried you were going
to end up becoming a cat lady
something tells me you're not besties
bling is my thing but even on a crappy
laptop screen you'll be rewarded with
better visuals than the itunes
visualizer on edibles
i mean just look at that water it's
insane how real that looks it's like a
water deep fake
if i were real water i'd be worried
starring
an exclusive dating app
i uh i i just um maybe it's like an la
specific thing but i just hear so much
about raya
and like the uh before this movie came
out that like that's where you go if you
to win a date with matthew perry or
um i heard channing tatum's on there now
post divorce
uh oh and like a lot of people like the
it's like the one right it's like the
exclusive one like the
you have to get invited to be on raya
yeah maybe this is like uh coastal bias
but that that was definitely the first
thing that popped into my head i mean i
think if you're hot
and from the midwest you could probably
get on raya
yeah let us know what it's like let us
know if you're hot and from the midwest
are you on raya
what what local celebrities can you date
um
jeremy roenick or other retired hockey
players that i can think of
i don't know um yeah i have a
look into rye it seems like a like a
funny place to be you can you can date a
lot of um
uh self-described influencers and uh
there's gotta be at least like three
cobra kai cast members around there
fighting some cobra kayak
yeah probably jamie kennedy no for sure
like a a a champion barista you know
that kind of thing
that's where you go all right keep going
an exclusive dating app fail core
does alan tudyk even remember how to
sound like people anymore
[Music]
zuko i know everything there is to know
about the shrimp in business
let me see that tong avoid the noise
daniel deadkim and when you really want
to say the b
word but you're in a disney movie she's
the backstabbing venturi bye bye
binturi's
pay up binturi let's finish this venturi
bye bye binturi
no good benturis benturi
now that's not a very nice way to
describe an old friend
the life aquatic with team sisu
whoa i got the glow look calling
yourself the last dragon if you must but
don't compare yourself to the real ass
dragon
you're not going to win who's the one
and only max
[Music]
your mind body and soul must be one
it's a sacrifice it takes hard work
it's a way of flying
oh good times uh i need to re-watch the
real last dragon after this
yes you do yeah terrific it's a lot of
fun it's on one of the
it's on one of the streaming services i
saw it pop up there no i know or i'll
just uh
listen to um power in the glory and do
some shadow boxing
um also good i work after you guys uh uh
thank you so much for watching i hope
you're having fun uh i am please
subscribe for more stuff like this
hit the like hit the bell you will never
miss another video
um with fascinating content like the
following
we have some deleted scenes of ryan the
last dragon uh if those are ready to go
let's watch them together hold on to
your hats for a film that changed
directors less than a year before its
release
has six credited writers and recast the
main voice super late into production
so it's either no surprise or a minor
miracle
that it became a huge bomb and or
massive hit
disney plus doesn't share their numbers
so no one really knows
if they make raya 2 the legend of korra
we'll know it worked
starring indonesia jones
rose taco
tuck and roll cat lady tiger undercut
raya's uh roommate the boondocks
masterchef junior mad i moody
king tong
crime boss baby a minion
and papa was a frozen stone
how to train your dragon
dream gems and dragons
well there you go that was fun stuff i
always feel like
we we always pick the wrong ones when we
watch the outtakes that's a shame
it's hard it's hard to know well how
it's gonna how it's gonna strike you at
the moment i do like the one that we
picked for
uh tuck tuck the alan tudyk uh character
because it is he's he's he's just the
guy you call when you need
noises now it's bizarre yeah
you guys do you see that that show
resident alien that he's doing on sci-fi
oh i've been meaning to check that out
it's fun i like it but it's also another
role of just like okay
alan in the scene we just need you to
make noises
but like an alien like no noise you've
ever heard go oh yes
the tragic the tragic loss of michael
winslow has been alan tudyk's gain
yeah he's really slipped into that role
i feel like
but michael winslow was more like
technological sounds whereas two dick is
more like
a beast you've never heard biological
but yeah there's there's some
overlapping more fauna
right well there's room yeah there's
room for everyone here there's room for
many voice men lady voiceman
noiseman um we got some fun uh some fun
questions from the chat keep them coming
if you got them
uh alan farina asks what movie would be
improved with a dragon
marriage story yep i think that's
pretty clear not gonna debate that what
what uh
how what scene or what role do you see a
dragon playing in marriage
um i think i would want the dragon to
play uh
the other lawyer i think i would like to
see right that's what i was gonna say
that's so perfect
i love ray liotta i don't know like
replace ray liotta with you right really
it was great yeah
i just thought maybe after adam driver
punches the wall we just cut to
the person living on the other apartment
on the other side it's a dragon who's
just like what the hell
oh i thought a dragon would fly out of
the drywall and and then
complete
and then they find uh love again just
break up
already every night
uh olivia pirano has a has an
interesting take uh do you think this
would have been a better movie if namari
had been the main character i think
would have been a much more interesting
story
well yeah i like that because exactly
what we've been saying like ryan is
too good in the beginning i don't really
feel like she has a
journey like like she's already very
trusting and loyal and cares a lot about
saving the world and this gem and brave
and namari's the character who actually
has a thing to learn about
trust and not stealing and you know like
so i think i think there's a little bit
more depth there maybe
yeah yeah i suck at that
um better benzy10 right uh uh
raya is the first heroine without a love
interest nor otherwise burly strongman
whom she can rely on isn't she
he's a burly strong man his name is tong
we just talked to the top
she's not relying on tom you know maybe
he comes in late in the picture yeah he
is a bloody strong man specifically well
cause i was gonna say what popped into
my head was moana but you got maui who's
probably more of a uh more relied upon
than tong certainly but definitely by
hollywood's burliest strongest i do
think um
well uh may kabir replied in the
comments brave was the first i think but
i'll go
one further uh that we just watched is a
lilo and stitch
um unless you count uh stitch is a burly
strong man but i don't
i i think he was more of a liability for
most of the movie he's not
yeah he's powerful but not burly yeah
you've got the older sister and lilo are
both uh
kind of on their own and and doing the
best they can and uh
i agree uh but this was another uh a
solid example of that two kinda like
she's got
burly guys around but she's not neither
anna nor elsa are really relying on them
but raya to me falls into the category
of like strong but boring
like she just is she's strong she wants
to
save the village save people and you
know she's
she doesn't really trust people whereas
i do think that if you had
like namari is kind of a more dynamic
character like the relationship with her
mom is complicated the relationship she
has with
the other tribes and stuff like that
like there was probably just more
to work with from a protagonist
standpoint and she's still plenty strong
um
she can still kick your ass uh with an
undercut
yeah it feels like she's she's got a
she's got an external conflict she's got
a quest you gotta
bring this here go there save this but
she doesn't
i don't feel like we get the internal
conflict like when she's not struggling
with anything she's just trying to do
the right thing
and like yeah she sat in a way that
every character in there is sad because
you know there's this huge loss to
everybody in all the different villages
um all right good this one's fun evan j
pretzel asks if you could see
an r-rated version or snyderized disney
movie what would it be
[Music]
my little mermaid cause like the
real version of that hans christian
anderson version of that is
dark yeah uh it's real dark so maybe
that one could be a good candidate
uh i i feel like uh and it's one that
like should get a remake anyway because
it's great source material and they kind
of biffed it
the first time the black cauldron like
okay that's a cool
big fantasy world disney could explore
again in a
better movie with updated animation and
yeah
give me give me the snyder verse version
of that world for sure
i think i've said it before but i want
the body horror version of the cars
franchise
where sure yeah they are just in
constant pain and
you know just i
what happens if you open all the doors
yeah and all their guts spill out
we're gonna find out yeah it'd be like
um a little bit
it'd be a lot of cronenberg because it'd
be a little bit the fly and a little bit
david cronenberg's crash which is the
superior crash
and we would see how that all works out
and then let's end on this uh langley
neely writes uh was where
was raya worth 30 bucks well it's worth
it when you expense it to fandom
oh yeah phantom bucks baby
it was worth it to me would you would
you have spent 30 of your own
hard-earned dollars and be satisfied
with your riot experience
i i mean i you know like look it's
i i enjoyed watching this movie and i
feel like this would almost be something
that i could see
getting on physical media or having a
copy of to like put on your tv
like while you write or something
because it is like i said a visual
feast like one of the best looking
movies in in some time
so almost on that level i'm i'm almost
inclined to give it a pass on all this
stuff but
i don't know 30 rental it's got to be a
pretty
freaking good movie to make to justify
that expense i think
yeah for 30 bucks i need to own it yeah
yeah exactly like if you were like long
would you plunk down 30 bucks for like a
4k
you know disc of variety you could put
on a huge tv
uh sure okay whatever yeah if i had like
two more
raya aged children sure but right if you
had to distract
uh some little monsters yeah whatever it
is yeah
but on tom and jerry again who cares for
rental
uh not this movie and frankly not any
movies that's worth a 30 dollar rental
um that's what i'm saying like you know
pretty
great like you we're we're talking movie
of the year to
justify a 30 rent well speaking of movie
of the year
that's next week's honest trailer and
that's that's your
that's the only clue you guys are
getting um
and you'll find out what that is next
week i know it's early in the year but i
think we've settled it already it's it's
if you currently have any doubt about
what it is it's not even for you
you could just skip next week yeah
exactly so we'll see you guys then
and we will be back tomorrow with more
sju goodness thank you lon thank you
danielle thank you audience we'll see
you soon
bye
[Music]
you